FOCUS ON THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION AND NOT WHAT'S
TRANSPARENT -- TRANSPIRING ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
JOINING US NOW, PRESIDENT AND
THE NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL, GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS
AFTERNOON.
BEFORE WE GET INTO IT, I WANT TO
PUT UP THIS GRAPHIC ON THE
SCREEN SO THAT PEOPLE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT THE TRENDLINES.
SEE THE GRAY LINE IN THIS, IT
SHOWS A TYPICAL SEASON DECLINE
OVER THE SUMMER AND 2018.
THE ORANGE LINE SHOWS A HUGE
DECLINE, OH, SORRY, THEY CHANGE
THE COLORS OF THE LINES.
SO THE BLUE LINE SHOWS 2019
WHERE WE HAD A BIG SPIKE AND
THEN WENT DOWN WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IMPLEMENTED ITS
BORDER POLICIES.
AT THAT RED LINE AT THE BOTTOM,
A LITTLE BIT OF AN ANOMALY,
BECAUSE THERE WAS COVID, BUT
TAKE A LOOK AT THE 2021 LINE,
AND THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT
UP-TO-DATE AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT.
BUT THAT GREEN LINE IS SHOWING
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE SPIKING.
WE ARE EXPECTING SOME 210,000
PEOPLE HAVE CROSSED THE BORDER
IN JULY, YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
>> AS LONG AS THIS
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO MAKE
BORDER SECURITY A POLITICAL
ISSUE, AS LONG AS I CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT ROOT CAUSES THAT
EXIST IN OTHER COUNTRIES INSTEAD
OF DEALING WITH THE ROOT CAUSES
RIGHT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES,
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THESE NUMBERS RISE.
AS LONG AS WE REWARD ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY, AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE
TO RELEASE PEOPLE INTO THE
UNITED STATES UNDER THE CATCH
AND RELEASE PROGRAM, WE CAN
EXPECT THESE NUMBERS TO CONTINUE
TO RISE AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
SEEING IT EVEN IN THE BRUTAL
MONTHS WHERE THE HEAT IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY STAGGERING.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS TREND GO UP.
>> John: 834 UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS IN A SINGLE DAY DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SENDING OUT
ALL OF THESE MESSAGES TO THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COUNTRIES, OH,
DON'T COME, DON'T COME NOW.
NOBODY SOUTH OF THE BORDER IS
LISTENING.
>> NO, BECAUSE ACTIONS SPEAK
LOUDER THAN WORDS, YOU CAN TELL
SOMEBODY, DON'T DO ANYTHING, OR
WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS, BUT IF
YOU DON'T FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
THAT.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO REWARD,
AGAIN, CRIMINALITY IS BEING
REWARDED ON THE BORDER.
IF YOUR ACTIONS DON'T MATCH WHAT
YOU ARE TELLING PEOPLE, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO VIOLATE
THE OLD BALL.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME KNOWING
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO --
THEY ARE ULTIMATELY GOING TO GET
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES,
WHICH IS WHAT THEY WANTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
>> John: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
HEALTH IMPLICATIONS, THE LAST
WEEK IN McALLEN, TEXAS, ALONE,
SOME 1500 PEOPLE WHO WERE
COVID-POSITIVE RELEASED INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE DOES NOT
HAVE A PLAN.
SAYS THAT IT IS WORKING ON ONE
AND ALL THE TIME THE DHS
SECRETARY IS SAYING THAT THE
BORDER IS CLOSED, THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS
GASLIGHTING PEOPLE OR IF HE
REALLY BELIEVES THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
>> NO, HE KNOWS THAT THE BORDER
IS NOT CLOSED, WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO IS DEFLECT, AND TRY
TO REACH TO THEIR BASE TRYING TO
GET THEIR BASE KNOWING THAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY WANT
THEM TO DO, BUT IN REALITY THAT
1700 PEOPLE, THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW
OF.
WE ARE RELEASING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE WEEK, MOST
OF THESE PEOPLE AREN'T BEING
TESTED FOR COVID, OR THEY ARE
BEING TESTED BY NGOs AND THEY
ARE NOT REPORTING BACK WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE, SO WE CAN DO TO
CONTACT TRACING.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
COMING INTO THE UNITED STATES.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE COMING IN WITH COVID, AND WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE WE
ARE RELEASING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT COULD AFFECT
THE UNITED STATES CITIZENS.
IN REALITY, THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS TAKING CARE OF ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSERS MORE THAN THEY ARE
UNITED STATES CITIZENS.
>> John: ONE THING IS FOR
SURE, SINCE JAVIER TOOK OVER AND
McALLEN, TEXAS, THE REPUBLICAN
MAYOR, WE ARE HEARING A LOT MORE
ABOUT THIS.
HE IS CURRENTLY LETTING THE
ADMINISTRATION KNOW HOW HE